i mean this is this is the one hope that  aryan's got there at nisha's very short  time and the queens are still on the  board making it how did he make that  move his hands were on his head oh  wow  he did this yesterday as well  he's he he's in a premium if he took a  while jedi master actually i want to see  that again  [Music]  what other parts of his body could he be  using  maybe  his young son came in and just kind of  went rogue on the mountain don't look at  me like that  that's twice in a row isn't it i i don't  know that's that's not approved that's  not a pre-move because black could have  played anything and this was not a safe  pre-move uh how is he doing this  the magician  he is clearly the jedi yeah he's like  you know use the force voice activated  he could be just like  telekinetic kind of he's like  like  i mean the mouse skill that's very  important right you need to actually use  the mouse yeah and it probably wouldn't  be a good idea